[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDI GUTMANS: Hi, I'm Andi
Gutmans, General Manager
and VP of Engineering for
Databases for Google Cloud.
Thank you for joining
us for Google I/O.
We have an exciting product
announcement to share with you
in this session.
For developers and
enterprises alike, the cloud
offers organizations
agility, cost savings,
and differentiated
capabilities that
allows developers to do
more than they could before.
That's why 75% of all databases
are expected to be in the cloud
this year.
Imagine, 40 years of proprietary
databases placed on premises
are moving so
rapidly to the cloud.
It's amazing.
New applications
are already being
built in a cloud-first manner,
and existing applications
are moving to the
cloud at a rapid pace.
Today, those
customers already have
many options on Google Cloud.
We offer a full suite
of database services,
from in-memory services,
like Memorystore for Redis,
to relational database services,
like Cloud SQL and Spanner,
to nonrelational
database services,
like Firestore and Bigtable.
All these services help
manage the complexity
of running your
databases so that they
are secure, simple to
use, and operate, and make
app development faster
and easier for you.
And we're really excited about
what these databases have
accomplished both in terms
of their ability to scale
and the number of customer
workloads we've served.
To give you a sense for the
scale of which our databases
operate, Spanner processes
over 2 billion requests
per second at peak.
Isn't that amazing?
Bigtable, our fully
managed key-value database,
processes over 5 billion
requests per second at peak.
Firestore is our serverless
mobile-optimized document
database, which
powers applications
with more than 750 million
monthly active end users.
So this demonstrates the
scale of the workloads
that our databases support.
Our databases help our
customers modernize their apps
and unlock the value of their
data across the GCP ecosystem.
For example, more than 650,000
Google Kubernetes Engine pods
securely connect to Cloud SQL.
And BigQuery users
query over 125 petabytes
of data in Cloud SQL
on average in a month.
That said, we still
have more work
to do to support customers
moving to the cloud,
especially for customers
coming from legacy,
proprietary databases.
These customers are
not moving to the cloud
with their applications as is.
They're working hard to
modernize by freeing themselves
of expensive licenses and
hostile business practices,
adapting to new requirements
around vendor portability
and taking advantage
of innovations
that only the cloud can deliver.
Those customers are
increasingly standardizing
on open source,
and in particular,
one open source
database, Postgres.
And there's a reason for that.
It has everything you would
expect from an open source
database--
the portability that has become
so important to enterprises,
and a license-free
cost model that
enables companies of any size.
But what's so special
about Postgres
is its rich functionality
and extensibility.
It provides a similar
and, in some cases,
better set of functionality
than the expensive closed source
alternatives.
It supports parallel
query, partition tables,
stored procedures, replication,
change data capture,
rich data models, and more.
Postgres's ecosystem
of extensions,
from foreign data wrappers
to geospatial support,
helps it address a wide
variety of use cases.
It's also ubiquitous.
It plugs into every major
application development
framework or ecosystem.
It's adopted by millions
of users in every industry,
from startups to
large enterprises,
and has demonstrated itself in
demanding customer environments
time and time again, giving
others the confidence to use it
in their own applications.
And the community is
friendly and welcoming
with lots of support for
those getting started.
We've worked with lots
of customers in Postgres,
running every scale
of application,
from early development to true
enterprise-grade applications.
And what we found is that,
despite the benefits,
at times, there's
too much burden
on developers to make it
run well in production.
We see developers struggle
to tune parameters
and configure their setup,
make difficult trade-offs
between reliability,
cost, and performance.
They're using layers of proxies
to get high availability,
carefully managing storage and
memory resources to prevent
out-of-disk and
out-of-memory errors,
and navigating the impact
of Postgres VACUUM.
Replatforming
business-critical workloads
onto open source
databases can be daunting,
especially when workloads
have strict scalability,
performance, or
reliability requirements.
Enterprise customers
moving from legacy,
proprietary database
expected additional support
in managing and scaling
their applications.
And, finally, we think
there are opportunities
to help customers do more
with their operational data,
like real-time insights and the
integrated use of AI and ML.
Don't get me wrong.
We think Postgres is phenomenal.
It's a phenomenally
mature database.
It's just that customers
have asked us to help them
solve some of these problems.
We believed we at Google
were uniquely positioned
to address these
user pain points.
So we started on the journey
with Postgres, the world's most
loved relational database,
and added the elements
we know best--
cloud-native
architectures, using
Google's unique disaggregated
compute and storage
architecture to scale
performance and improve
availability, an
awesome engineering team
assembled with database experts
from across the industry,
and our DNA of AI and
ML to make everything
about running a database easier.
Alloys are made by melting
and fusing elements
together to create something
new with improved properties.
Today, we're excited to
announce the preview of AlloyDB
for Postgres.
Combining the best of
Google with full Postgres
compatibility, AlloyDB
is a new database service
that is ready for your top-tier
relational database workloads.
AlloyDB provides
industry-leading performance
and availability,
so it can handle
any commercial-grade
workload you throw at it.
Full Postgres
compatibility means
regaining the freedom to
run your applications when
and where you want
and benefiting
from the entire
Postgres ecosystem.
AlloyDB is four times faster
than standard Postgres
for transactional workloads.
It's also more than
two times faster
than Amazon's comparable
Postgres-compatible service
for transactional workloads.
This means you can
scale transactions well
beyond previous limitations
and get better performance out
of fewer resources and much
smaller database instances.
And best of all, query
performance scales
linearly as you add
more compute resources.
We also know that
customers use Postgres
and other operational databases
for a variety of workloads,
including real-time
insights and reporting.
AlloyDB delivers up to 100
times faster analytical queries
than standard Postgres.
Isn't that amazing?
That's with zero schema
changes and no need
to move data around.
We're really excited about
what this means for end users--
super fast, real-time
analytical queries directly
against your
operational database.
At AlloyDB's core is
Google's innovative approach
around completely disaggregating
compute and storage.
This approach has
enabled us at Google
to build truly unique and
differentiated systems, where
we don't just separate
compute and storage at fixed
layers of the stack, but we
have complete flexibility
to add compute as
much or as little
as needed within a
system, which enables
us to deliver the most
performant, efficient,
and scalable systems.
For AlloyDB, we've built
a new intelligent database
optimized storage layer
that scales separately
from the database instances and
offloads work from the primary.
But we're not the
first to do that.
What's so special
about AlloyDB is
that we're leveraging Google
technology to disaggregate
compute and storage at
every layer of the stack,
including the
storage layer itself.
That allows us to deliver
a truly scalable system
with predictable
high performance
for both reads and writes,
and lots of flexibility
to continue to innovate
in creative ways.
Zooming in a little bit, you
can see the storage layer
in more detail.
It's powering fast,
predictable performance
by eliminating I/O bottlenecks
and offloading work
from the primary
database instance.
And its regional by
default, enabling fast,
bounded recovery times,
and low-lag read replicas.
But again, what's so important
here is that, as you can see,
the storage engine
itself has disaggregated
compute and storage.
This means that we can very
transparently rebalance load
if there's a hotspot
and make sure
that a particular shard gets
the compute resources it needs.
It also allows us to scale
I/O because we can flexibly
add more processors in the
intelligent storage engine
to adapt to the load.
Again, this is all fully
transparent to the database
layer.
The storage service isn't
the only technology powering
fast, predictable performance.
AlloyDB features automatic
data tiering between DRAM,
and ultrafast cache,
and durable storage.
That means you get the
availability and scale
benefits of our scale-out
storage service,
plus the price performance
benefits of tiered caches.
We also intelligently organize
your data between those caches.
In DRAM, we use both
row-based and columnar formats
to maximize query performance.
Machine learning
infers your workload
and auto-populates these
caches effectively.
We continuously monitor your
workload and dynamically
decide which columns
and tables belong
in the columnar store
then automatically convert
them to columnar format.
And so when a query comes
in, the query planner
will smartly choose between
row-based, columnar, and hybrid
execution to optimize
performance for every query.
Within the columnar
store, AlloyDB
builds on the
Single-Instruction,
Multiple-Data, SIMD capability
of modern processors
to speed up query execution.
Cache misses go to a
second ultrafast tier cache
before hitting durable storage
to maximize price-performance.
This architecture
allows us to deliver
the best performance
for both transactional
and analytical workloads.
The vectorized columnar
execution engine
speeds up analytical queries.
And intelligent storage
service powers very low-lag
read replicas, so you're always
querying an up-to-date version
of your data.
That means you can
run super fast,
real-time queries on your
operational data directly with
zero impact on your
operational workload--
no schema changes, no
additional indexes,
no additional configuration.
In fact, you might
even be able to drop
your existing analytical
indexes to further improve
transactional performance.
AlloyDB delivers real-time
insights out of the box.
To see that in action, I'm
going to turn it over to Viral.
VIRAL SHAH: Hi.
I'm Viral Shah, a Lead
Engineer for AlloyDB.
As Andi mentioned,
AlloyDB allows
you to supercharge your queries
with zero schema changes.
Let's walk through a
call center use case
to see how much faster
AlloyDB is than PostgreSQL.
Let's say I'm managing a
call center CRM database.
I have 1 terabyte of data
partitioned by day of month
with approximately 100 GB on
the size for two months of data.
The tables hold the
clients' interaction data,
including the time they were
put on hold before the call was
answered.
My CRM database was initially
billed as an operational store
to [INAUDIBLE] our call
centers, and continues to do so.
But I'd like to get some
quick insights on our users'
experience.
So I'd like to
run a few queries.
First, I'd like to understand
the average customer's hold
time during the months of
July and August of 2021.
As I'm building my
dashboard, we will
be running three more
queries concurrently
that are looking for the total
number of clients who called
during those months, the client
that had maximum hold time,
and the time of the
peak call volume.
We have built a dashboard in
our favorite visualization
tool, Looker, to compare
the performance of the two
databases.
On the left side, we
have an AlloyDB instance.
And on the right side, we
have a PostgreSQL instance.
The results of the
four queries are
displayed below each of them.
Before we dive in, let's
talk about the configuration.
We have two like-for-like
VMs with 32 cores
and 256 GB memory in each.
For the AlloyDB VM, we
have provisioned a larger
60-GB columnar cache alongside
a smaller 10-GB buffer cache,
whereas the PostgreSQL VM has
a large 100-GB buffer cache.
PostgreSQL's buffer cache
and AlloyDB's columnar cache
have been prewarmed
and populated
with the tables for
two months of data.
I'm now going to
rerun the queries
by refreshing the local cache.
As you can see,
AlloyDB has already
processed the query, whereas
PostgreSQL has some work to do.
I think we'll have to
fast-forward this video
to allow PostgreSQL's
to catch up.
But how fast was AlloyDB?
Let's look at this
dashboard to dive deeper.
We see that the queries
running on PostgreSQL instance
took an average of 164 seconds,
while running on an AlloyDB
instance, they completed
in less than a second.
AlloyDB was nearly 160 times
faster for these queries,
and I didn't have to add any
indexes or change any schemas.
Cool.
ANDI GUTMANS: That
was a cool demo.
Thank you so much.
We're so excited about the
performance of that AlloyDB
offers customers and the new
capabilities and insights
it unlocks.
But this architecture
also enables
a new level of reliability
and availability.
We offer four-nines
availability SLA
that not only includes
unplanned failures,
but database
maintenance as well,
so you can better
serve your end users.
AlloyDB automatically
detects and recovers
from most database failures
within 60 seconds, independent
of database size and load.
It means recovery
is not only fast,
but also very predictable.
Our architecture also supports
online instance resizing
and database maintenance.
The primary instance can resume
normal operations in seconds,
while replica pull updates are
fully transparent to users.
And finally, we'll talk
about this more in a bit
when I cover how easy
AlloyDB is to manage--
we've done a lot of
work to make sure
that other reliability
issues you see,
like out-of-memory errors
and out-of-disk errors,
are a thing of the past.
Writes on AlloyDB scale
linearly with core
count up to the largest instance
supported on Google Compute
Engine.
Reads scale
horizontally, with loads
balancing across more
than a thousand vCPUs.
Each read replica has its
own vectorized columnar store
that's auto-populated by
access pattern recognized
by the machine learning
algorithms on that replica.
And, of course, storage
scales automatically
as well due to that scale-out
intelligence storage engine
I described earlier.
Talip is going to show us how
seamlessly reconnections scale
with AlloyDB.
TALIP OZTURK: Hi.
My name is Talip Ozturk.
I am the Engineering Manager
for AlloyDB read pools.
Read pools allow you
to horizontally scale
read connections by
adding more nodes.
Today, I want to
show you how you
can increase your
read performance
by adding more nodes.
Here, I have a cluster
with a primary and a read
pool of two nodes.
I'm expecting an
increase in traffic,
so I want to double the
read capacity on my cluster.
It's very simple.
Just edit the pool and change
the node count from 2 to 4.
Because this update
takes a few minutes,
I created another cluster
with multiple pools.
As you can see, the first
pool only has one node,
the second has two nodes,
and the third has four nodes.
They are all backed by the same
primary and the same database
storage.
That means, regardless of
the endpoint I connect to,
I will be querying the
exact same database.
Because node counts
are different,
I expect that my
query per second
should double from one node
to two nodes and two nodes
to four nodes.
Let's see if that's the case.
Here, I have a
client VM, and I will
be running a standard
pgbench select-only workload
for 10 seconds.
Let's run it against the
first pool with one node.
Its IP ends with 28.
It is 71,000
transactions per second.
Let's try the pool
with two nodes.
Its IP ends with 15.
Just going to change IP,
and that should double,
and it should be more
than 140,000 per second.
Great, it's 149,000
transactions per second.
Now, let's see if we
can double it again.
This time, we're going to be
connecting to the last pool,
and its IP ends with 19.
That should be around 300,000.
Awesome, 300,000
transactions per second.
As you can see, we can literally
scale our read performance
by adding more nodes.
I can scale up and down in
just a few minutes at any time.
It's super easy to make sure
you have the right capacity
for your workload.
I want to show you one more
thing before we end our demo.
As I said before,
all these read pools
are backed by the same primary.
So what happens if
the primary dies?
Can we still use the read pools?
Let's see.
First, let's see if we can
connect to the primary.
I'm just going to use psql.
Primary IP with 2, so I'm
just going to connect to it.
Great, we can.
Now, I'm going to crash the
primary and also its standby
with this command.
Now let's see if he
can access the primary.
Primary is definitely down.
Let's see if we can
access the read pools.
Great.
Even if the primary
is down, read pools
can continue running just fine.
Hope you enjoyed the demo
and thank you for your time.
Back to you, Andi.
ANDI GUTMANS: That
was an awesome demo.
Thank you.
AlloyDB is also
really easy to manage.
We use machine learning and
other adaptive algorithms
to provide
comprehensive database
monitoring, troubleshooting,
and optimizations.
AlloyDB features
autopilot systems
to help both automatically
manage and dynamically adapt
the database systems to the
needs of the customer workload
they're running.
You no longer need to worry
about complex database
management tasks, such
as memory management,
vacuuming, and data tiering.
AlloyDB automatically
addresses them for you.
AlloyDB seamlessly integrates
with Google's portfolio
of distinctive AI
and ML services.
For example, Vertex AI
will be available at launch
for easy inferencing
with AlloyDB databases.
We're also making it easy to
build machine learning directly
into your applications with
intelligent transactions.
AlloyDB is preintegrated with
Vertex AI, Google Cloud's
artificial
intelligence platform.
Developers can create
a model in Vertex AI
and then call it within
a query or transaction.
For example, a payment
processor can immediately
flag a new transaction
and flag it as fraud.
You get high-throughput,
low-latency augmented
transactions without
having to write
any additional application code.
We're really excited
about the new capabilities
that AlloyDB offers, but we also
haven't overlooked the basics,
the awesomeness of Postgres
that brought us here
in the first place.
AlloyDB is fully
compatible with Postgres,
including broad extensions
and flag support.
We're launching with
Postgres 14 compatibility,
but we'll have cadence
with the latest releases.
So as Postgres gets better,
AlloyDB will get better too.
Move your Postgres
application as is
with no need for
application changes.
Just use pg_dump and pg_restore,
or use our Database Migration
Service.
And finally, we know cost
is a concern for developers
and enterprises alike.
That's why we're committed to
predictable and transparent
pricing.
No license fees, no
opaque I/O charges--
simple, usage-based pricing
for both compute and storage
with industry-leading
price-performance.
But don't just trust us.
Here's what some
of our customers
are saying about AlloyDB.
From Deutsche Bank to
Nokia to PayPal and more,
leaders love it, as it
allows them to modernize
faster and reduce costs.
And developers love the
Postgres compatibility,
along with the scale and
performance of AlloyDB.
AlloyDB is helping
customers do something
they couldn't do before, whether
it's modernize an existing
workload in the cloud,
solving a scaling issue,
reduce management overhead,
or enable real-time insights.
What this means is that for
your Postgres workloads,
we offer you not one, not
two, but three fully managed
services.
Cloud SQL is our
enterprise-ready, fully managed
relational database service
for Postgres, MySQL, and SQL
Server you get the exact
same awesome, open Postgres
you run elsewhere with strong
management, availability,
and security capabilities
of Cloud SQL.
AlloyDB is our fully
Postgres-compatible database
ready for your
top-tier workloads
and for modernizing
your legacy proprietary
databases in the cloud.
And then, of course,
Spanner, which
is our transformative
relational database
service with unlimited
global scale,
strong consistency, and up
to five-nines availability.
We have also introduced a
Postgres interface for Spanner
so that developers can
take advantage of Spanner,
using familiar tools and skills
from the Postgres ecosystem
to build transformational
applications that
need unlimited scale and
always-on availability.
We strongly believe that Google
Cloud is the best home for all
your Postgres workloads.
Now, to help more enterprises
standardize on Postgres,
we recently announced
Oracle-to-Postgres schema
and data migration support in
Database Migration Service.
This offers a heterogeneous
migration path for Oracle
to Postgres.
Database Migration
Service integrates
with the Ora2Pg open source
tool for schema conversion
and provides serverless
data movement and monitoring
for migrations.
This is available in
preview for Cloud SQL,
and we expect to support this
for AlloyDB in the near future.
Database Migration Service
will also support easy upgrades
from Cloud SQL to AlloyDB,
so you can run your Postgres
workloads on Cloud
SQL now and rest
assured that you'll be able
to later move them easily
to AlloyDB to take
advantage of AlloyDB's
unique and differentiated
capabilities.
Lastly, we know that
migrations can be challenging.
Therefore, we have invested
in a comprehensive end-to-end
program to help make
your migration experience
fast, easy, and cost effective.
We have recently announced
the new Google Cloud Database
Migration Program.
This program provides
tooling and resources
for assessments, project
planning, and implementation.
These efforts are
further amplified
with incentive funding
designed to reduce
the cost of your migration.
Take advantage of
this program and offer
by getting in touch with
your account teams today.
So here's how you get
started with AlloyDB.
You can create a
cluster right away,
using our UI, API,
or gcloud CLI tool
and start ingesting
and querying data.
If you're coming
from Postgres, simply
use pg_dump and pg_restore to
get some data into AlloyDB.
And with the
introduction of AlloyDB,
this is what our rich cloud
databases portfolio looks like.
We're excited about the business
and technical transformations
our databases can drive for you.
So I invite you to try the
preview of AlloyDB today.
We're offering the preview for
a limited time at no charge.
Learn more at
cloud.google.com/alloydb.
With that, I'd like to
thank you for joining us
at Google I/O. We hope
to partner with you
to modernize your
databases and accelerate
your data-driven
business transformation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]